[Music]
in free sex news oh my men submitted by
who why the Malaysia jamali in why a
blogger was jailed after she offered
free sex online and hundreds showed up
oh why should be held wait if she
offered paid for sex then that would be
prostitution so what it's really have to
be free I feel like I don't know oh girl
yeah girl off hot hole I'm not in I
wanted how is that a crime to offer your
body up for free it's charity how can
you have sex with a hundred guys a
hundreds showed up Oh hundreds yeah yeah
hundreds
yeah moral why don't we do it out here
like I've never seen that happen
what like where they're like hey free
sex show up over here say hello it's
called College campus frat house and
sorority houses if all those guys busted
a nut in her and gave her a special
cream pie and if she got pregnant then
that means that sperm was really strong
huh whoever's whatever sperm wins you
know it's dope even our ovaries aren't
thirsty guys even in their sperm are
[ __ ] thirsty because they're all like
running yeah and the ovaries like not
[ __ ] yeah but we don't get
periods [ __ ] anyways I'm surprised you
know cuz you act like you get one that's
what you get their own like males are
like PMA you get it all the time you're
on it right now you're on your period
real it's male PMS I got a no emotion
cuz I can't feel my feet that's David
like really get cranky and like
irritable are you sure it's not a real
[Laughter]
maybe ours is a reaction to your Joe
alright well let's see what happens if
you put three guys in the house and
three girls in the house separate let's
see what happens well just guys he's
gonna have a messy house we're gonna
pick the guys for you then yeah
sure because you guys are probably want
to live together like now okay what are
the guys I'll just entertain this what
are the guys um a guy that's very
fashion-forward notice yeah you're gonna
straight-up name my name from kynges
logan paul okay I'll put Casey in the
house with you guys us for okay and
wasps Tyler Oakley who else so just
those two what is so it's just for white
guys in a house uh oh
that's very doable okay uh three months
New Year's bang in the Sahara Desert so
four guys are just a buff [ __ ] by me
that's yeah yeah yeah
what do you mean they're gonna pop what
do mean I'm gonna start dominance I'm
gonna be the alpha male on the buff up
there what do you mean you never been to
jail I've never been to jail but I know
that's a real man he's gonna make a jail
situation you know who else went to jail
this blogger yeah nineteen-year-old well
I'm gonna come out of white surfer there
you go I'm looking out like this awesome
friends you start dabbing everywhere me
high on coke I don't think he knows who
those people are yeah I don't know who
they are glasses they're not so glasses
he has white glasses I mean that's I
want you to guess clear glasses
well you [ __ ] go suggest to us
people that I don't [ __ ] know these
people I know who the [ __ ] they are
educated we just wasted Nicky's good
Segway are you guys happy all right so
this blogger chick she's a 19 year old
she goes by the username of Schengen yay
and I think it'll find her
oh it's China that's why it's illegal
they don't like you having sex over
there's so many babies that's why right
yeah she posted but she posted on her
social media with this video I'm about
to show you with the caption that says
somebody come get me sex for free six
three one six which is her sweet number
and she also location tagged it the
Hilton were talking this is a video what
she so close to camera what was what was
the guy he was like he said I I think
the the way you look is really cute
[Laughter]
that's so funny well you don't know the
language stuttering just sounds like
Chinese I like the way you look it's
really cute
yeah he was probably busted in that she
turned the camera around his Michael
this woman she posted it on her wave oh
and WeChat and that [ __ ] just went viral
to the point where thousands like about
three thousand people either asked about
or showed up to the Hilton she was like
legit trying to give out the puss or was
she trying to trap them for something
else so she's saying that it was all
just a joke and she was like oh I was
just having some fun cuz shortly after
she posted that she checked out of the
hotel so the hotel Keys they filed an
official complaint against her yeah
because it disrupted business yep and so
she was charged arrested in charge on
prostitution charges pop and disrupting
the Hilton Hotel today she was jailed
for 15 days oh my god I didn't even know
that Chinese gangsters existed are you
serious yeah thanks are all over the
world I know now i know but i think
because i grew up chinese like i just
think all chinese girls are like my mom
oh like there oh yeah you have a
mustache grow out the armpit hairs and
not give a [ __ ] about [ __ ] i just
thought that's all chinese women I think
that's all girls I mean eventually yeah
some point yeah but that's my view of
the Chinese culture but then I forget
that they're skanks and bad people and
gangsters and nerds and Geeks and
athletes everywhere in the world it's
true like when you you know that's so
why is that maybe it is because of that
cuz we see our mom and that's like the
type of women that we saw yeah all I see
too is it's not sexualized is
light-colored blue jeans and white
sketches get your pugs so basically she
pulled a prank and then got jailed for
it I think she'd just be she's just a
rich chick that is just like get me and
then she's like we're leaving yeah she
like some lifestyle blogger or whatever
exactly she does but I was wondering if
China has like their own version of CAM
girls up bling girls dot-com or
something I don't know yeah who knows I
couldn't find like what exactly she's
blonde you want to come over and do it
at six guys are so [ __ ] horny it's so
crazy yeah so true free sex that's like
[ __ ] if you tell Asian people there's
a free like haircut at the barber shop
everybody lines up anything for you
anything free even at a discount like a
$2.00 disc if it was the other way
around so let's say it was like the
finest dude on earth with the nicest
penis there probably be like ten girls I
showed up there would never be 10,000
women I will also like I don't know
who's one guy that you three girls would
like to [ __ ] uh Jason Momoa I just want
to stare at him cuz he's so beautiful
who do you want to [ __ ] though like he's
really hot that I saw the other day
that's a dude who Captain America what's
his name Chris Evans yes he is a [ __ ]
good look Clark miss Evans because we
need a unanimously here's the thing
though if a guy showed his penis I'd be
like yeah but can you make me laugh cuz
he that's what makes me know
that's most girls though yeah that's why
I think that guys are more visual so a
girl can be like boobies come have sex
and they're like okay and girls like if
it was like penis come have sex it's not
the same I think they thought it proves
the difference look how hard it is for
them to even agree and hard hard for
them to even say they'd be down to [ __ ]
someone like I think girls sex drive
versus guys drive it has to do a
personality your problem is this so
before you see you see this hot guy
right then you're like well let's figure
them out we don't do that we see the hot
woman she apparently she already goes to
Harvard that's crazy we could we could
take half a woman that's just bent over
because I don't get turned on unless
they make me laugh like you just look
like a walking one too much that's what
it's all blobs you're all blobs until
you make me laugh yeah yeah hey my sex
drive is higher than Steve's sex drive
but he is this visual and - personality
base that's all hmm
I think it's like for women you gotta
feel safe to do it with that person or
feel like comfortable or there's that
you there's that rapport well there's
gonna be a mystery exactly but guys like
there's already chemistry if she got
nice titties and ass yeah that's the
chemistry she goes to Harvard in my mind
yeah kids everything we say she laughs
all the time for some reason I don't
know I dated short guys fat guys skinny
guys tall guys all different he's all in
one right now but like the one thing
they all had in common was that they
made me laugh
does lonely it's the sparks right yeah
it's the sparks and it's like oh like I
feel a chemistry even during like a long
dry spell like you haven't
dick in like six months no that's
different that's like my cutoff is six
weeks okay there ever got longer than
you have a dick perfect okay okay it's I
this happened to me so that happened
during a dry spell I was single I just
went to comedy clubs and like I would
perform too but also like get hell away
funniest comedian you're funny we're
[ __ ] tonight it was a fun time cuz
it's like oh I know this isn't going
anywhere I just need to get it dick cuz
you know I would never date another
comedian we're so pressing cuz the guy
guys won't be like oh my god personality
i'ma [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of that like oh
my god honestly I'm a [ __ ]
i'ma [ __ ] the honesty out of her leo no
one says that I'm gonna try to do that
deep [ __ ] that's clear you be your
darkness I make it funny and I will [ __ ]
you but they have to be like somewhat
attractive at least really like honestly
I don't you know I that is though if you
go to her Instagram you're looking at
throwback Thursday picture you'll see
where she came from what [ __ ] it crazy
that was actually a pretty good one yeah
literally look like you volunteer at the
library on purpose like it was your safe
space hey what's wrong with that David I
actually did go to library my lunch
breaks at school because I was a
moderator on the M&M board on the M&M
message board I was a modern all makes
sense down that pitcher I was like how
do you look older when you were in high
school yeah
[Music]
[Applause]